es ist ein wirklich verrückte rekord der
mars rover curiosity hat das bislang
größte bild des roten planeten überhaupt
geliefert
es besteht aus mehr als 1000
einzelbildern und hat 1,8 milliarden
pixel für diese aufnahme brauchte
curiosity fast eine ganze woche
und der grund für die entstehung dieses
fotos ist ziemlich verrückt klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen schon seit acht jahren also
seit 2012 ist der mars rover curiosity
auf dem mars unterwegs und das obwohl
die mission ursprünglich nur auf zwei
jahre angelegt war
er sucht hier nach spuren von frühen
leben und damit nach daten die einen
exorbitant wichtigen wert für
forschungsteams weltweit haben mit dabei
waren auch schon viele super spannende
bilder vermuten planeten die nicht nur
fachleute weltweit fasziniert hatten
doch jetzt hat die nasa eine aufnahme
veröffentlicht die alles bisherige
übertrifft es handelt sich um eine 360
grad panorama aufnahme die sich aus mehr
als 1000 fotos zusammensetzt das bild
zeigt viele details des aktuellen
standorts des rovers im hintergrund zu
sehen ist der rand des kraters gale ein
gigantisches ausgetrocknetes seebett
hier wurde er quasi geparkt um die
aufnahme zu machen mittendrin befindet
sich der berg mount sharp der rund 5000
meter hoch ist somit seinen gipfel höher
als der krater rand fachleute sind
überzeugt davon dass dieser charta vor
milliarden jahren einmal mit wasser
gefüllt war hier ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit anzeichen für leben
aufzuspüren also besonders hoch der mars
rover hat außerdem den kleineren kraters
lenkers fotografiert der sich im inneren
des gale kraters befindet und einen
durchmesser von fünf kilometern hat
vorne ist curry city selbst zu sehen und
ebenso seine spuren die er im roten
geröll hinterlassen hat für die
aufnahmen wurde das teleobjektiv der
mast kamera und ein mittel winkel
objektiv eingesetzt entstanden sind die
rund 1.000 einzelaufnahmen zwischen dem
24 november und dem ersten dezember 2009
10 die bilder wurden dann zur erde
geschickt wo die riesige datenmenge von
forschenden wieder zu einem bild
zusammengesetzt wurde damit die
lichtverhältnisse stimmen wurden die
aufnahmen jeden tag zwischen 12 und 14
uhr
der mars zeit gemacht an mehreren tagen
hatte der rover damit jeweils mehr
als sechseinhalb stunden zeit benötigt
doch das ganze hat sich gelohnt denn das
beeindruckende panorama bild das aus 1,8
megapixeln besteht ist das größte bild
dass der mars rover jemals von seiner
umgebung gemacht hat dabei kamen die
aufnahme total spontan zustande
und zwar jetzt kommt der verrückte grund
denn ende november 2010 wartete der
rover auf weitere anweisungen hatte
somit etwas leerlauf so hatte er damit
angefangen bilder von sich selbst und
der landschaft zu machen
am schluss noch einen coolen tippt
übrigens von mir wer brokdorf hat kann
sich das originalbild bei der nasa
herunterladen
aber achtung die datei ist 22 5 gigabyte
groß also am besten nicht über mobilfunk
runterladen kommt das leben vom mars
spannende frage mit der sich dem von us
comics tv beschäftigt also anklicken
anschauen und astor comics tv abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran